good morning believe nation today's
message is follow your own dreams over
to you PewDiePie follow your own goddamn
dreams now what your mom wants you to do
what your dad wants you to do not what
you think you should be doing but doing
what you want to do more than anything
it's I it's it's been said so many times
before but really if you don't make your
own decisions in life someone else is
gonna make them for you and by the end
of it you won't be happy so you might as
well do what it is you want to do so I
think somewhere along the lines in
everyone's life you have to make the
decision at some point whether you are
living your version of your life or
someone else's version of your life
because along the way people are always
going to have opinions on what you
should and shouldn't do
they're gonna have opinions and what
careers you take have opinions on what
school you should go to have opinions on
whether to start that business or not to
move to that country or not have
opinions on what color socks you're
gonna wear today people will have
opinions on everything and if all you do
is live your life according to other
people's opinions and expectations you
are never going to get to the point
where one you're happy and two you're
actually doing the thing that you can be
great at it's not gonna happen now in
the early days of being a human being
you listen to your parents right you go
to the classes in schools that they send
you to when you listen to them and
hopefully you're a little bit respectful
as well but as you get older at some
point you need to realize that you're an
adult human being and you need to make
decisions and take accountability for
your life as well if you are not where
you want to be if you are in the wrong
major if you're taking the wrong classes
if you're in the wrong business or wrong
career it's not your parents fault it's
not your friends fault it's not your
advisers fault it's your own fault you
that's it it's your fault you are
where you are because of you period you
can't blame other people for your
decisions for the rest of your life so
if you want to break free you have to
take that responsibility and start doing
something about it
I find that you're gonna have two kinds
of people who will be the haters in your
life the people who will give you the
bad advice the wrong advice the
unsupportive advice the first group is
gonna be the people who are jealous of
you the people who are just nasty people
haters are the little man and they tell
you all the reasons why you can't do the
thing that you want to do you want to go
and start that business and they tell
you how you don't have the education and
the connections and the money and the
resources and you've never done that
before and who are you to think you can
go out and do that and nobody from this
town has ever gone done something that
big all of those people and often if you
look at their life it's really just
based out of fear insecurity and
jealousy maybe at one point they took a
big shot they tried to follow their
dream they tried to do something
important and it didn't work out and
because they didn't have success now
nobody around them can have success now
every idea everybody tries to do
something on their own that's a bad idea
and they need to be the anchor for
everybody around them right you're
trying to rise up and they want to pull
you back down they're gonna be that
anchor around you and those are the
easier people actually to ignore their
words may sting they may be more
visceral and more angry with you but
recognizing that they haven't done the
thing that you want to do makes it
easier it's now the second group for the
people who are doing it out of love
they're not doing it out of fear and
jealousy they're doing it out of love
you know your parents may tell you not
to go and start that business not to go
and chase that dream of yours your
closest friends may tell you that's
really risky don't go out and do that
and they're doing it out of love because
they care about you it's not that
they're jealous or they hate you they
love you the challenge is they see
success success through their eyes
through their narrow limited view right
and success maybe go and get a safe
secure job go out and be a doctor or be
an accountant they're your lawyer go out
and do this safe thing
or do what I did right I went and I did
this and I had success so you should
follow in my footsteps because that's
what success looks like and the way to
break through is understanding that your
version of success does not look like
theirs and what really helps us to think
about these people that are giving me
advice my parents of people around me
the haters these people who are throwing
opinions on me
we're telling me all these things that I
should be doing that I'm not have they
done what you want to do have they gone
where you want to go and if the answer
is no then who are they to give you
advice how can they tell you what to do
if they've never done what you want to
do if anything you want to take the
opposite of their advice I don't want
your life and so I'm gonna go this way
and do the opposite of what you're
telling me now you don't have to be mean
and rude and in their face about it
especially if it's coming from a place
of love from them but in your head
that's what you're thinking these people
have not done what I'm trying to do you
don't know how to give me the advice to
help me get there I need to find
different mentors different guides a
different path that is different from
what they're telling me and if you
shrink down and you don't accept that
and you say you know what you guys are
right because you're afraid to stand up
to them then you're never ever ever ever
going to reach your potential never
you're never gonna be fully happy you're
always gonna wonder what if you're
always gonna think that you could be
doing more and the longer you stay on
that path the more boxed in and boxed in
and boxing you're gonna get and you've
built a life for yourself where it's ok
to shrink down where it's okay to play
the smaller game and just live inside
this box where every time you get
challenged by anybody
you've conditioned yourself to shrink
down and just accept that that's the way
life is and you're now gonna teach this
to others you're gonna teach this to
your friends you're gonna teach this to
your kids you're gonna teach plain small
and limited thinking on to the next
generation to your kids and I want that
cycle of me
ah created to stop with you I want you
to practice being bold I want you to
practice listening to yourself
understanding what you're all about and
what your dreams are when you have an
idea you start you go for it you push it
forward I want you to be a source of
inspiration for the people around you
well you don't need to yell at them and
show them off and tell them how they're
wrong you're just gonna go out and do
your thing and you may fail in the early
days but if you stick out and you
persevere you're going to have success
and that would be an inspiration to the
people around just say look what he's
doing
look what she's doing huh I can do
something too
that's what I want for you and I hope
you want it for yourself to believe so
the question today today is I'm curious
what was the hardest part about living
your own dreams what was the hardest
part leaving the comments below I'm
gonna join in the discussion I also want
to give a quick shout out to Reynaldo
Espinosa from self-built Empire calm
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word it really
really really means a lot to me so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much loved and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
hey believe nation we're also looking at
doing a top 10 on PewDiePie and here is
a sneak peek at some of the clips that
we're thinking about using I hope you
enjoy the bonus my job is so easy I can
literally do what I feel like and it's
kind of amazing just the fact that I can
play video games for a living that when
I realized that for the first time like
I was almost getting teary I like it was
my dream has come true oh they'll be
happy not to be number one
I would like what I'm just a nerd who
plays video games I don't I didn't seek
the spotlight your parents will tell you
you can be whatever you want to be in
life which is true but what a lot of
times they don't tell you is that you
have to work really hard to get there
and another thing maybe more importantly
is that you have to take risks you have
to win venture into the unknown and you
might not know what's gonna happen and
that's scary but I think it's always
better to try the night trying no matter
what
except myth is not not even once